.
Pasquale Harrison-Julien
s'y est re
- Bonjour et bienvenue
chez Appartement Rimouski.CeCeCt
pour savoir si vous avez des
logements abordables entre trois
et demi et quatre et demi.lalalr
à Rimouski après y avoir vécu
25 ans.
- Les logements sont rares. s s,
elle doit trouver pour le 1er
juillet.
- 775 par mois, Internetriririr?
- Oui.
- Ok, et c'est un trois et demi?
- Un appartement assez gpopopope
seize ans, une fin dinininine
sur deux.
- Moi, je vais ê
moi là, bientôt là. Si ça
continue de mê c c c c'est ça...
c'est mon futur qui se plante
là.
- C'est Camille...
- Au serviidididide à
la recherche de logements
à Rimou
que mal d'aider les locataires
qui n'arrivent pas à t
un toit.
- Pour la propriétaire, là,
elle devrait te rappeler.
- Mais comme le ta
d'inoccupation est de 0,2 %,
la tâche est ardue pour
il y a un an.
CAMILLE BE-V-V-V-VINET, inter.,
serv., aide, logement, Rimouski
- Le prix que je vois, c'est
logements qui sont assez grands,
c'aiaiaiaiment cher.
La majeure partie de mon
travail se passe au téléphonesee
cherchent un logement.isisisis r
différentes solutions.
C'est pas : "On va appeler aulst
nous trouver un logement."
Il n'y a pas assez de logements,
donc on peut juste les mettre en
contact avec les propr d d d d .
- Oui, Daniel?
- Oui.
une nouvelle situation urgente.
DANIEL BÉLANGER, , , , serv.,
clientèle, Office d'habitation
- L'enjeu, auparavant, était
qui avaient moins de capacités
financiè l l l les gens qui
avaient un historique de mauvais
payeur, peut-être. Mais là,
sont... des fois des couples qui
so l l l le marché du travail
les deux. Donc, on parle de
personnes qui ont une capacité
- C'est ça. On va construireuxut
être prêts d'ici deux ou trois
semaines.fafafafafafafafafafafas
se retrouvent à la rue, l'Office
d'habitation de la région
transforme des unités
de dépannage en logementmememems
pour accueillir des familles
qui pourront y rester pour une
période maximale de trois mois.
- La grosse surpri q q q q q q e
à avoir des grandes familles qui
étaient en grosse difficulté. On
n'était pas capable les loger
dans un studncncncncncncncncncna
fait, c'est qu'on a converti
des quatre et demi en logement
qui vont pouvoir accueillir
de
- Bien moi, depuis 98, je suis
par ici, et je n'ai jamais eu
ça, moi une crise du logement
de même.
- Après avoir épluché
des annonces depuis des mois,
le découragement de Lucie est
palpable au point où c'est elle
rue lorsqu'elle était en voiture
avec son amie.
- Moi, je fais de l'anxiété
beaucoup depuis ce temps-là.
de kilomètres de là, dans
la région de Mate e e e taux
d'inoccupation est un peu moins
dramatique : 1,7 %.
- Moi, je suis né dans
demi c'était petit.
aiaiaiain Dubé est  le
coordonnateur du Comité logement
de Matane, qui existe depuis
- Fait que... imaginez,jojojojoe
retrouve dans la quarantaine,
cinquantaine avec un demi ouana.
- Dans cette région peu habituée
à un effet de rareté aussi
marqué...
- Ce n'est pas de la tarlelelels
de leurs droits. Il les
accompagne aussi, parfois jusque
devant le tribunal administratif
du logement. p p p p p p p p p e
facile, ces temps-ci.
- Non.
- Il nous fait rencontrer
ce locataire l l l l l l l l lùx
tardent à être réalisés par
le propriétaire pour nettoyer
un dégât d'eau.
- Pu
de difficultés à se trouver
un logement en ce moment?
SYLVAIN DUBÉ, coordonnateur,
Comité logement de Matane
que la moitié du monde qui vient
de me voir, c'est des gens de
la classe moyenne.
Comment puis je vous aider?
50 à 60-75 % de leur revenu pour
avoir un toit. Alors, si
les aide pas, on va tous payer
la facture.
logement, là.
Cette année, il vlelelelement
avoir des ménages, des familles
qui n'auront pas de logement
- Il y a une qualité de vie ici,
à Matane, on est à cinq mia a at
intéressant pour des gens qui
aiment le plein air.
- La région a attiré de noenenet
la pandémie, mais les logements
sont insuffisants pour répondre
à la demande. La Ville a adopté
plusieurs incitatifscocococococ,
mais la création de nouvelles
unités prend du temps, beaucoup
de temps.
EDDY MÉTIn n n n n n n n n n n s
peut-être un an ou deux. Est-ce
qu'il pourrait avoir certains
mécanismes des gouvernements
pour édédédédédédédédédédédédéds
de construction? Ça, ça serait
une belle réponse à apporter.
- À la fin du mois de mai,
Québec a annoncé le versement
de 78 millions de dollars pour
répondre à l'actue L L L L L L a
notamment des centaines de
ménages qui ont un appartement
non subventionné à payer leur
loyer. La sommererererererereret
temporaire d'urgence. Mais,
est-ce que ce sera suffisant?
- Moi, je parle, là, pour tout
le monde qui est en charge
des logements, des gens qui sont
po
mère avec les enfants, puis qui
n'ont même pas les moyens de
se payer 1000 $ de logement.
Même s'ils travaillent. Même
minimum!
à espérer que l'accès au
logement devienne un enjeu
électoral cet automn